good evening the near collapse of
equitable life brought home to millions
of policyholders what happens when an
insurer can't make good on its promises
and whilst it doesn't attract as much
attention as Banking Regulation
Insurance Regulation is vital to the
economists smooth running well the man
in charge of that is Sam Woods deputy
governor of the Bank of England and
chief executive of the Prudential
regulatory authority he joins me now for
his first broadcast interview Sam great
to see thank you for joining me now
while everyone knows that the bank
oversees and supervises the banking set
a few people may necessarily know that
you oversee insurance why is it so
important this is a huge sector here in
the UK two point four trillion in assets
which to give you a view as a sense is
bigger than GDP and today we're
announcing a series of reforms to the
way that we regulate that sector which
basically are about cutting bureaucracy
making life will be easier for the
smaller firms but this is no bonfire the
regulation and the reason for that is
directly to your question the huge
numbers of people depend on this
industry in one example is 27 million
people in this country have a motor
insurance policy
another is six million people are
relying on these companies to pay their
pensions in a moment so while we are
going to make the regulation more
efficient we're not gonna go soft in
these people at risk now insurance is
one of those sectors in which Britain
punches above its weight globally how do
you balance the need to retain that
whilst being fairly tough with the
insurance companies well the first thing
to say is industry in this country is
alive and well and the best evidence for
that is that returns are healthier at 9%
return on equity for the major insurers
the insurance sector is grown by 10%
over the last couple of years so I think
there's absolutely no evidence to
suggest that the weight of our
regulation is somehow impeding the
competitiveness of the UK insurance
sector but one thing we do have to have
an ID to of course is smaller firms and
that we're being proportionate in terms
of how we apply our regulation to them
and one of the things we've said today
is that we will cut the reporting burden
on those firms by up to half that may
mean though that insurance some some
lines may be less aggressively regulated
than they were previously I I wouldn't
say any more regulation is aggressive
but it is all meant
be robust and the reason for that is
that people depend on these services in
a very vital way I spent quite a lot of
time with policyholders over the last
few months to remind myself of that and
when you talk to people about what they
rely on insurance companies to do you
realize it's very important they're
there to make good when things go wrong
and I mean you've touched on this in the
past in some of your speeches you've
seen some really quite emotional cases
at times of where insurance companies
have done the right thing but they could
only do that because they were being
properly supervised yes well you know
when you hear these cases here
particularly when people have a critical
illness or in a some kind of terrible
accident and you realize you know the
the kind of emotional value of what
insurance companies are doing in those
situations you guys is very important
that we pay attention to our job which
simply put is to make sure the insurance
companies have got enough money to pay
out when things go wrong and of course
all being the case that is hopefully
that'll be the way it continues now what
about competition in the sex this is
something that the Treasury select
committee has been looking at they would
like to see you encouraging competition
more what's it what's your response to
that I mean it's competition losing out
right now
well so I don't think so and you know
there are many points of agreement
between us in the Treasury select
committee I think it's a great thing
that Nicky Morgan and that committee
have decided to look at this point of
regulation which is you say often goes
much less noticed than banking but there
is a slight difference of view about
whether we should make the competition a
primary objective of the Prudential
Regulation Authority and I'm not very
enthusiastic about that for two reasons
one is to be honest the most important
contribution we can make to competition
is as a referee so setting the rules for
everyone so that unscrupulous firms
can't come in and undercut the
well-managed firms that's our core job
and secondly the benefit of focus I
think the lesson of the financial crisis
in this country is if you've got a
regulator with ten objectives they
probably won't do anything very well
worth pointing out though I guess that's
if you look at things like motor
insurance premiums have been coming down
very sharply in recent years suggest
that there isn't an awful lot wrong with
competition well I think there's been a
pretty ferocious competition in that
market in particular and that's been
including through air players coming in
from outside the you
and it's true that we generally don't
think there's a major competition
problem in insurance markets another way
to look at that is we've authorized 26
new insurers over the last four years
seems to me that's a reasonably healthy
rate what about insolvency - now this is
the pan-european here wide Insurance
Regulation directive what happens post
brexit will that stay in place for
British insurance well in that is a very
good question - which none of us
currently know the answer and it will
depend of course on what kind of a deal
the government wants to strike and you
know we're looking forward to what the
prime minister says on Friday so the one
point I would make though is that it's
been an enormous effort to bring in this
new regulation we're now in the process
of tidying it up but I think if you ask
the insurance companies do they want to
embark on another completely new
regulatory journey at this point most of
them would say no right all right well
amen to that I'm sure if any the
insured's are watching some words great
to say thank thank you very much